hey guys and welcome to this week's
video I thought I would impart my wisdom
and give you guys 35 things I have
learnt at 35 YouTube personality emily
hartridge dead at 35 after a reported
traffic collision involving her electric
scooter Emily's death was announced in a
post on her Instagram page Saturday that
read in part quote Emily was involved in
an accident yesterday and passed away
we all loved her to bits and she will
never be forgotten the London
Metropolitan Police released a statement
explaining that they responded to
reports of an electric scooter being in
collision with a truck on Friday morning
they continued by stating that a woman
in her 30s had suffered serious injuries
and was pronounced dead at the scene
they're asking for information or
witnesses to the crash and added that no
arrests have been made yet the YouTube
community has shared their condolences
on social media including jack mate who
called Emily so polite and lovely London
Hughes shared this photo and wrote my
friend is dead and now I feel completely
sick I'm still not entirely sure what
I'm doing to life
Emily was known for her candid and
hilarious videos that explore topics
like travel romance and growing up I
feel I'm at a really nice stage in my
life and that's it really I'm rambling
because I never had videos I'm just
gonna go so thank you very much I love
you all back